ce soit des braconniers et des
trafiquants à l'assaut de l'ours noir
dans nos forêts c'est très désagréable
quand je retrouve des ours tard un
dépotoir qui est en jeu c'est une
ouverture au niveau du foie il le trac
l'apab ils sont prêts à tout pour avoir
bien plus que ça qu ils veulent ce
véhicule biliaire qui vaut plus cher que
de l'ivoire d'éléphant s'offre un peu
d'air et scully biliaire des plus
grosses paires forme les fermes douce
c'est ce que j'ai vu du pire poste on a
un deuxième reportage extrêmement
troublant pour vous ce soir et on vous
prévient que certaines images sont
difficiles à regarder on vous parle du
majestueux ours noirs qui vit dans nos
forêts et qui est menacé par des réseaux
de braconniers et de trafiquants qui
veulent chasser pour sa vésicule
biliaire pourquoi parce qu'en médecine
traditionnelle chinoise on croit que
cette ville possède de nombreux
bienfaits
[Applaudissements]
est unique c'est le seul mammifère à
produire une quantité significative de
bill juillet 2018
une centaine d'agents québécois de la
fonte sont réunis dans un hôtel de
jonquière on prépare les troupes avant
le grand déploiement prévu le lendemain
grand vraiment les pieds genre qui en
faisait une spécialité qui allait
jusqu'à prélever une centaines d'ours
seulement pour la vésicule la biologiste
ce film assez rappelle l'époque où l'on
abatte est massivement lors ce noir
c'est donc pour le protéger que depuis
1998 il est interdit d'acheter de vendre
ou de posséder des visiteuses biliaire
d'ours noirs ce petit organe qui
al'allure d'une pochette est utilisé en
médecine traditionnelle chinoise pour
traiter entre autres des problèmes de
foie ou le rein est parfois pour
augmenter la virilité pochette c'est
aussi le nom de l'opération qui se
prépare et à laquelle nous avons eu un
accès privilégié à brens musée un gars
on vise à démanteler un réseau de
braconnage qui sévit dans plusieurs
régions du québec
quand vous aurez les vielles bon je veux
qu'ils sachent qu'on se trouve le fiel
ou la bile d'ours vaut des milliers de
dollars sur le marché international pour
bien comprendre le fonctionnement de ces
réseau de braconnage
il faut remonter à 2002 c'est
l'opération america qui fait alors de
manchette
l'opération se préparer depuis six mois
et les 200 agents de la faune qui y ont
participé ce matin n'ont pas raté leur
coup de la viande de gros gibier des
véhicules mais surtout plus de 260
vésicule biliaire d'ours noirs michel
gay a participé à l'opération america
c'est vrai qu'on trouve à savoir des
hausses tuer avec l'abdomen ouvert sans
vésicule biliaire je peux vous confirmer
que c'est arrivé à plusieurs reprises la
personne pouvait abattre juste pour sa
vésicule biliaire ainsi que c'est
parfois pour les pâtes dont nous
retrouver tous genres carcasse à des
endroits différente des régions
différents à l'origine de ce type d'
enquête
il y à l'information recueillie grâce à
la ligne sos braconnage et soyez ce sont
nos yeux nos oreilles en forêt souvent
america a révélé trafic illégal de
visites bélières d'ours noirs aux
nombreuses ramifications à la base de ce
réseau des chasseurs et trappeurs d'ours
qui récolte les visiteuses biliaire et
les vendent à une intermédiaire un
premier intermédiaire qui lui vaut
acheter d'un package dans américain le
plus gros revendeurs était un
fonctionnaire du gouvernement fédéral
marc langlois était aussi responsable de
l'association des trappeurs de chaudière
appalaches pour avoir transigé plus de
300 visites hull
il a écopé d'une amende de près de 48
mille dollars ils approvisionnaient un
commerçant coréen de toronto qui lui les
exporter aux états unis d'ailleurs la
journée d'amérique hall 20 novembre 2002
simultanément à toronto n'ont saisi une
centaine de véhicules hier un autre
intermédiaire au profil surprenant
nguyên quang binh biochimiste et
chercheur à l'université laval
les agents de la faune ont retrouvé chez
lui plus de 100 véhicules biliaire c'est
à son ode à région québec ramassait des
véhicules billard à des fins
d'exportation
le scientifique les exporter au vietnam
il a payé une amende de près de 33 mille
dollars puis à quitter le pays
[Musique]
american 2002 a porté un dur coup à ce
trafic
mais quelques années plus tard c'est
reparti de plus belle
da partir victimes à 2 2 mais qu'est ce
qu'on a pu constater qu'il y avait
certaines formes de structures qui était
remis en place pour faciliter le
commerce devises que le billet car
l'appât du gain est un puissant moteur
des chasseurs et rappeur qui empoche 100
à 200 dollars la vésicule des
intermédiaires qui obtiennent le double
une fois vendue sur le marché asiatique
local sa valeur augmente encore et
exporté à l'étranger
une visite qu elle peut valoir jusqu'à
dix mille dollars
en 2018 après une enquête de trois ans
c'est maintenant au tour de l'opération
pochette de frapper
moi c'est vous c'est notre cas
s'attendre et une en donner le goût aux
sénateurs 21 à toutes les autres équipes
là c'est un go donc les hippies bonne
chargement hollywoodien les équipes sont
déployés en même temps en mauricie sur
la côte-nord au saguenay-lac-saint-jean
et dans la région de montréal
l'objectif d'avoir des rencontres en
simultané et a effectivement d'éviter la
destruction ou la perte de preuves coup
ne pas que les personnes dans notre e
puis ce comité nous avons décidé de
mener notre enquête avec l'aide d'une
collaboratrice d'origine chinoise le but
vérifier si on peut se procurer des
véhicules biliaire ou des produits à
base de bill comme ceci dit autrement
elle se rend dans différents commerces
et cliniques de la grande région de
montréal
la majorité des commerçants répondre ou
c'est illégal mais deux lui laisse
entendre qu'elle pourrait s'en procurer
sous la table ou après la chasse à
l'ours du printemps
rien de bien concluant pour l'instant
mais notre enquête se poursuit
de nombreuses organisations
internationales milite pour freiner le
commerce des espèces sauvages 28,6
d'être les animaux sauvages sont devenus
des marchandises car il rapporte de
l'argent
dr jan schmid bareback travail pour la
world animaux protection cette
organisation mène depuis des années des
enquêtes sur plusieurs continents pour
dévoiler l'ampleur du commerce de la
bile l'organisation a accepté de nous
livrer en primeur et résultats obtenus
dans le grand toronto en 2018 sur une
look tête on est allé dans 25 magasins
et six d'entre eux vendaient de la bile
d'ours certains produits manufacturés
venaient de chine ou du japon
mais il y avait aussi des vésicules
entière l'organisation avait obtenu des
résultats semblables
quelques années auparavant en 2007
c'était un magasin sur quatre est en
2018 encore un magasin sur quatre
ça n'a pas changé en dix ans même si
l'illégalité de ce commerce est mieux
connu et que les lois sont plus sévères
une visite de notre collaboratrice
semble soudain porté fruit un thérapeute
chinois la contacter quelques semaines
plus tard la dernière fois vous m'aviez
demandé de chercher des véhicules d'ours
vous en voulez toujours jeune ami qui
est fiable
il connaît des chasseurs aux états unis
mais je ne sais pas combien vous
voudriez payer pour une visite culte
j'en ai déjà acheté une auparavant mais
je vous le demande combien perrier vous
pour sept véhicules d'ours ils veulent
la porter ici discrètement c'est
difficile interdit de les vendre ou de
les acheter
la loi nous interdit de conclure cette
transaction nous n'irons pas plus loin
et quand nous avons joint le dr thanh il
a tout nié
[Musique]
de retour à l'opération pochette au
saguenay-lac-saint-jean de nombreuses
visites ils ont été saisis mais une
expertise sera nécessaire pour faire la
preuve qu'il s'agit bien de partis
d'ours
la prochaine année là particulier ça a
été la saisie de trois congélateurs
complète a été justifiée par le fait que
et ont servi à faire du commerce illégal
de fourrure on a trouvé aussi des
oiseaux de proie de la viande des
parties d'ours et des oursons congelés
[Musique]
après la pause notre collaboratrice fait
une rencontre prometteuse
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
la fédération des trappeurs
gestionnaires du québec tient son salon
annuel durant trois jours exposants et
visiteurs se rencontre pour parler de
leur passion commune
ce tracker nous montre son plus récent
piège à ours en nouvelle-écosse la vente
de la vistule miliaire de l'ours noir
est permise
nous avons demandé à des trappeurs s'ils
souhaitent que le québec adoptent la
même position
je serais pour ça mais ça draine
réglementation puisque la fourrure a
perdu de sa valeur ce serait pour lui un
revenu supplémentaire une solution
braconnage même rêvé de refaire des
plans avaient des trappeurs qui voyait
croyait chevalier 92 parra n'est pas
normal
pour cet homme ça ne ferait
qu'encourager les abus jusqu'au pour la
légalisation de ce sujet doit faire quoi
toi la chasse pour choisir vésicule
biliaire trop jeter l'eau sabré son mari
va durer ce collectionneur de vieux
piège regrette le temps où transiger
véhicule était légale somme de 9 ans en
moyenne chargeant jean-pierre notre
fédération préconise la légalisation des
véhicules d'hier comme activité
économique puis comme revenus
additionnels pour les trappeurs on
trouve qu'effectivement c'est un
gaspillage plusieurs centaines midi
la la fédération souhaite gérer ce
commerce des véhicules biliaire prélevés
sur des ours a battu légalement nos
livres seraient complètement ouvert pour
le contrôle par les agents de la faux
pour le ministère des forêts de la faune
et des parcs
pas question de revenir en arrière pour
le moment au protection de la ressource
pour ne pas que québec soit il la plaque
tournante au niveau du commerce
international de vis que le média
il y à 70000 ours noirs au québec et on
en chasse et trappes autour de 6000 par
année ne trouve ce n'est pas en danger
mais c'est une espèce à surveiller de
près car sa visite il ressemble en tout
point à celle de ses cousins asiatiques
qui eux sont en voie de disparition
décimé entre autres par les braconniers
[Musique]
en chine le commerce de la bile d'ours
est légal est florissant depuis les
années 80 il existe là bas des fermes
ndour spécialisée dans la récolte de la
bile une pratique très cruel des ours
capturés et enfermés dans des cages
étroite où on pompe l'habile directement
de la vésicule biliaire performe les
fermes bourse c'est ce que j'ai vu de
pire c'est déprimant parce que ce sont
des animaux sensibles
ils comprennent ce qui se passe les
mettre en cage pour la vie c'est affreux
avec les fermes d'ours la disponibilité
de la bile s'est accrue et la demande a
augmenté et maintenant cette forte
demande pour la bi les combles et non
seulement par les fermes mais aussi par
le braconnage des ours sauvage leur
véhicule est convoité et ce malgré le
fait que la substance active dans la
bile d'ours la cdu des ca et synthétiser
depuis longtemps par l'industrie
pharmaceutique des les gens pensent que
prendre de la bile d'ours est bon pour
eux parce que les ours sont forts
puissants et sauvage alors souvent ils
préfèrent le produit qui vient
directement de la nature au début des
années 2000 notre ancien collègue
raymond st-pierre a visité un refuge on
accueille ces colosses rescapés d usain
jasper notoire de l'himalaya 220 kg est
anesthésié pour subir une opération qui
va le libérer une douleur extrême qu'il
a dû endurer pendant des années
jasper un cathéter ou petit tube en
métal qui sort de son ventre le cathéter
a été implanté dans la visite biliaire
de l'ours pour extraire la bile de
l'animal à l'époque le gouvernement
chinois parlaient d'éliminer ces fermes
selon des organisations internationales
de défense des animaux
il y aurait toujours plus de 10000 ours
prisonnier de ses cages
[Musique]
nous sommes de retour au québec à saint
boniface en mauricie notre
collaboratrice se rend cette fois ci
dans un salon de la fourrure elle
s'informe auprès des trappeurs s'il est
possible de trouver des véhicules
biliaire
si les basques une série d' illégale
si jamais le maillot
les gardes et qu'on les garde côtes
anglais
pour m laisser tomber les freins
un des trappeurs marcel otis va plus
loin
les deux
c sipa iv on ne pense pas parce qu'on
n'a pas le droit mais si j'ai quelque
chose que
faut sauver la mémoire adresse internet
ils se rencontrent une semaine plus tard
dans un café la conversation porte
d'abord sur l'achat de pathos chez les
amis puis notre collaboratrice revient
sur le sujet qui l'intéressent de
s'affoler fait sécher le cas j'ai
vraiment où j'ai fait j'ai commencé
ce soit chez les espoirs soulevés dans
la maison de l'un de ceux que je connais
et que je suis mis à les apprivoiser le
chasseur quelqu'un qui va dire c'est
illégal mais je m'attends à voir un
joueur c'est illégal
donc on peut pas être pour cela la
position du ministère est clair à cet
effet
les amendes pour vendre de visites
biliaire peut varier entre 1800 et 5500
$ par infraction et jusqu'à 16 mai
dollars s'il ya récidive à 6 pour
dissuader
pour la grande majorité des personnes
assez important pour dissuader les
personnes de poursuivre dans ce commerce
mais si vous avez démontré que c'est
encore ya encore une possibilité de
commerce donc pour certaines personnes
l'importance des sanctions liées au
commerce ou ne sont pas assez importants
confronté au fait monsieur autistes nous
a dit qu'il n'avait pas réellement
l'intention de lui fournir des véhicules
biliaire
des ours torturé pour faire grossir leur
véhicule biliaire notre enquête se
poursuit après la pause
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
si on earth heureux sac rempli de
véhicules biliaire nous sommes au
laboratoire d'expertisé bio légale à
québec
la biologiste de vicky albert analyse
une partie des véhicules saisis lors de
l'opération pochette les véhicules c'est
ce qu'ont eu les six qu'on a saisi en
plus grande quantité ou en fait qu'on
aura porté ici au laboratoire pour
expertise en plus grande quantité
nous on reçoit les véhicules biya puis
en fait on nous demande de venir
confirmer l'espèce fait janvier 2019
les expertises sont terminées et les
procédures judiciaires peuvent commencer
pour l'instant le bilan est le suivant
on à 176 constats d'infraction ont été
émis à 40 5 défendeur trop total de plus
de 450 milles dollars potentiel d'amande
pour une somme totale
cette vaste opération a aussi mis au
jour le trafic entre le québec et le
nouveau brunswick
l'inspecteur françois chiasson raconte
comment ses agents ont infiltré le
réseau
il y avait une personne près de montréal
qui étaient intéressés
acheter des véhicules biliaire il
approché quelques chasseurs au nouveau
brunswick
les agents de la faune se sont fait
passer pour des chasseurs a fait
d'attirer l'homme issu de la communauté
vietnamienne
on a fait quelques ventes afin d'établir
que les glaives est en fait un réseau ou
un commerce
l'acheteur est venue la province environ
cinq fois pour racheter des fistules
biliaire les rencontres avaient lieu
dans le stationnement du casino à
moncton
on avait préparé une dernière vente le
15 ou 2018 le 15 ou l'indivision
question ne s'est pas présenté mais ça
va envoyer
deux autres personnes à sa place un
homme et une jeune femme lui aussi de la
communauté vietnamienne
la femme c'est qui a mené la
condensation avec le faux chasseur lui a
donné une enveloppe contenant 1500 $ et
puis le faux chasseur lui a donné sachet
contenant 14 vie séculière
une fois la transaction complétée
le couple est arrêté les accusations
contre le chauffeur de la voiture seront
retirés
les procédures contre la jeune femme
sont encore en cours elle pourrait faire
face à une amende de 4000 dollars et
jusqu'à 7 jours de prison et l'homme qui
lui a confié cette mission est dans la
mire des agents fédéraux
nous on a en quelques secondes
indivisibles
de la région de montréal qui semble être
selon nos renseignements 1 semble être à
la tête de ce réseau la chair d'un
jordan est responsable de l'application
de la loi sur la faune au fédéral il
intervient quand les activités illégales
dépasse les limites d'une province ou du
pays
nos agents sont en train de regarder des
preuves qui ont été saisis pour
déterminer est ce qu'il y avait d'autres
liés ailleurs au pays ou à l'extérieur
du canada
selon l'inspecteur chiasson la présumée
tête de réseau aurait eu des exigences
il avait fait mention aussi de de dire à
nos chasseurs si que l'ours s'offre un
peu les véhicules biliaire devient plus
grosse
alors ne tuez pas tour est de laisser la
bête souffrir un peu
un ours pressé produit plus de bill donc
sa visite qu'ils rapportent davantage
les accusations de cruauté animale
pourrait s'ajouter au dossier
il ya eu une grosse augmentation de
trafic des espèces sauvages depuis la
dernière décennie
cette pièce aux allures de caverne d'ali
baba renferme de nombreux produits de la
faune intercepté aux frontières peau de
grand félin comme de rhinocéros défenses
d'éléphants et de narval et dans ce
triste décor cette petite pochette elle
aussi très recherchés les mêmes forces
économiques qui alimentent sa demande
pour les espèces exotiques d'afrique
c'est aussi présent chez nous
les autres sont paul est en elle non
plus est-ce qu'on est dans une situation
d'urgence de feu rouge non mais c'est un
feu jaune puis il faut faire attention
[Musique]